American woman April Corley survived a
mistaken attack by Egypt's military is
urging President Trump to confront
Egypt's president and make him take
responsibility helicopters built in the
US were used in a 2015 attack that
killed April Corley's boyfriend some
members of Congress are pointing to that
incident as they try to block a deal to
sell ten more american-made Apache
helicopters to Egypt
Errol Barnett is spoke with Corley in an
interview you'll see first on CBS this
morning
Erol good morning good morning look you
may have seen April collie before she's
a Hollywood stunt woman and dancer who's
appeared in movies and commercials and
even toured with Madonna all of that
before suffering injuries in an attack
on her tour group in Egypt that changed
her life well now she's speaking out on
television for the first time with hopes
President Trump holds Egypt accountable
april Cauley choreograph moves for
madonna and skated her way through mike
myers movies my life was really about
glitter and rhinestones and rollerskates
and I was living my dream until 2015 and
a vacation in Egypt with her boyfriend
Rafael he is a soul mate to me one day
in the desert their tour group was
attacked I was thrown to the ground by
like what felt like a mysterious force
but when I looked back the sand was
black and I got up and I couldn't walk
Cooley badly injured said she laid there
for nearly four hours calling out for
Rafael he and eleven others died in the
attack there was blood everywhere and
the helicopters kept coming back and
shooting at us Coley later learned the
helicopters were flown by the Egyptian
military and made by the United States
Egypt has said that they thought I was a
terrorist for what reason did they
explain I have no idea because we had no
weapons
we had permits for each tourist
destination
that we were going to Egypt's tourism
ministry said the group was in an area
off-limits to tourists and quote were
mistakenly dealt with the Egyptian
government offered each survivor
$140,000
but collie is asking it to pay more than
14 million for the scar she bears on her
body and others she says you can't see I
went to the beach recently to meet some
of my girlfriends and a helicopter came
over and I ran in fear for my life
the State Department tells CBS News it
has raised April's case with the
Egyptian government she and of a menthe
center that's Patrick Leahy say they
hope President Trump will bring this up
with Egypt's president when they meet
next week at the White House so they're
really pushing this issue and her case
specifically that's good she's speaking
up good to see you Harrell